they cross the border any way they can
in trucks
on foot
and Donkey cards
they left behind homes in Ruins and
corpses in the streets that couldn't get
a decent burial
on chadian soil they bought trucks to
take them to the biggest refugee camp in
eastern Chad holding tens of thousands
of people all with one sad story or more
mother of two is pregnant with her third
child
she and her oldest son Muhammad both
witnessed the murder of her husband
she's putting up a brave face for now
but it's unclear how long it will be
before she finally breaks down
the children keep asking me when will
their father return home I tell them he
will join us soon
how old his son Muhammad was snatched
from his father's arms before the
attackers shot him and only three other
men right in front of the family
most of the refugees here are from
Sudan's Western therefore a region that
has seen two decades of conflict
majority of the 55 000 refugees in this
Camp are undocumented this means they
cannot access Aid as you can see there
is no single tent decent for human
habitation here
the refugees accuse militias of
ethnically cleansing the region to gain
dominance
Halima so her brother taken away by
gunmen
one week after there is no news of him
they shot his friend in the leg as for
my brother they knocked him down with a
car beat him and took him back to
elginina I was told that he was killed
conditions in the camps are bad there
isn't enough food or shelter here but
they have water delivered by military
trucks but people must kill for at least
an hour to get some
government and Aid agencies are
overwhelmed
um
every day we receive on average three to
four thousand people across the border
into Chad I can tell you we don't have
enough resources to cope with the influx
back at the border family members look
across the frontier hoping to catch a
glimpse of relatives making it to safety
but many will leave disappointed hoping
for a better luck the following day
Ahmad Idris Al Jazeera adrei Eastern
chart